is he alleging that there are books
being banned because there are
indigenous or black people in them it's
the most ridiculous thing I've heard in
my life
he's alleging but this this part here is
operative right this is the key the
lgbtq plus Community I agree Brock it is
kind of a weird coincidence that all of
the books that are being banned because
they have pornographic content in them
are being supported by the LGBT
community and your party maybe don't own
that so loudly what do you guys think I
think one thing that's interesting is a
lot of these books and I've spoken to
moms for Liberty about this
um and about the different books and
different moms who are like you know we
don't want genderqueer we don't want
flamer we don't want a lot of these
books a lot of them are actually graphic
novels and I wonder if it would be if
anyone would even notice if they were
not graphic novels because that's where
you see this you see you know uh
lesbians fellating a strap-on and gender
Square